oh you can't
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up guys dopaziola here welcome
back to the dope as usual podcast we're
here to talk about life problems drugs
accomplishments and everything in
between today guys we have our first
guest
i am [ __ ] excited it's our first
guest and it's somebody i actually
really really like
hello this is josh wolfe comedian joshua
thank you for coming down
dude my pleasure thank you so much for
having me this place is so
cool man it looks [ __ ] awesome it
looks like a notebook in high school
[Laughter]
are we friends check yes here dude i
remember doing that oh yeah passing that
note did you ever get a no
check back where you're like son of a
[ __ ] i was just talking about that
everybody was mean to me in school i
never got no [ __ ] note
where i did the thing dude remember that
[ __ ]
oh yeah i don't know how to make it i
never knew how to make them yeah i don't
know how to make them at all
i was just telling this story dude it's
so embarrassing when i was like in
it gotta be sixth or seventh grade there
was this girl i was dating
and um she told me she was like yeah
i'm gonna let you go with my shirt
tonight and i was like oh
okay hold on this is 11 to 12 year olds
keep going no there's like sixth
grade seventh grade probably so 12 or
13. it's over there right all right and
she was like uh
she was uh well maybe it was sixth grade
and she goes i'm gonna let you go up my
shirt tonight and i go oh
okay all right and um so we get to her
place and i start
her please well her gets her parents
yeah her parents house her place
her parents house and and and um her
parents were out in a movie
and so i was like so how do we do this
and she was like
i guess you just you know and so i go
okay and i go
like this to go up her shirt she goes no
not the front the back i go oh
she goes you can go up the back of my
shirt and i was like okay
i go so your boobs in your bag so she
would push out her shoulder blades shoot
yeah no stop it you know
i i would thought it was super cool
because she was like she was like yeah
she called them reverse boobs and i was
like this is a real story
sixth grade dude i thought i was she
thought this was cool i
think she was she thought she was
offering up something that was good
but yeah dude so i just so there you go
she's
popping her shoulder blades out and
you're feeling up her shoulder blades
yes you're massaging her
kindness because she was like these are
my reverse boobs and i was like okay
but in sixth grade here's the deal guys
here's the deal
you had you ha you've had porn in your
pocket since you were
10. like i didn't know maybe reverse
boobs was a thing what do i know
honestly you're in sixth grade some
older kids oh you what'd you do
oh yeah how old is it i guarantee you
they were hyping your ass up
oh what do you mean you touched her back
like [ __ ] yeah i thought
i thought that was a deal yeah you
eventually went from back
to front that's like really [ __ ]
awesome i gotta be honest that's
dude it was but at the same time pretty
dumb you know
i hope i hope whoever that was hears
this and goes [ __ ]
yeah that was my reverse her name is
tiffany i don't remember
no you do
[Laughter]
but i just you know wait how the [ __ ]
did we get into this
we were
oh we're talking about school school
yard oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
gotcha that's right um
so no my uh my school years are not the
same as yours
no you never reverse boob somebody never
reverse boob to anybody
sounds kind of hilarious i got to be
honest man
i i will tell you that like the when i
thought about it the other day i was
like
that's the dumbest thing i've ever heard
that's the dumbest thing
why would i but i mean but he went into
sixth grade smiling even harder the next
day it's it's
it was worth it it was so worth it i
felt so grown
up you know what i mean it's just like
dude the first guy
used to sell me weed he used to sell i
was
dishwashing at the time right and uh i
was about 14 years old
maybe 15 and he used to come walk right
back in the kitchen
and tell you weed right back you work
there nope
just walk right back real quick what
state are you in massachusetts
i don't know anything about my man would
walk right back into the kitchen
billy harrison did gene he wore jean
vest you know what i'm saying my man was
straight out of dazed and confused
didn't give a [ __ ]
and he would walk right in the kitchen
man and sell you weed
wait out what do you mean did he already
wait
no weigh it out weigh it out you're in
the kitchen no no no it was weighed out
oh okay
but here's the deal man so he gave me
the he gave me a bag and you know it
used to
seeds and stems used to be a thing used
to be weed yeah right was weed
exactly but this dude i was like hey
um this this bag has a lot of seeds in
it and he goes
that's good i go oh is it he goes hey
you know you can plant those he said
i just give seeds to my best customers
and i was like really i go can you hook
me up with more seeds he goes it's going
to mean less weed and i go okay
yo my man saw me gotcha yeah he got you
good
but at the same time it's not even his
fault
no that's not his fault if you were like
no they get some more
he didn't try to trick me but he let
yourself i
gave it to you he gave it to you until
my bro i told my brother one time my
oldest brother i was like hey let me
show you something and he goes what i
opened up just a drawer and it just had
a [ __ ] ton of seeds he goes
what are those and i told him the story
he goes you're so [ __ ] up you might as
well have
beer cats yeah he was like what do you
think you're gonna he goes and even if
you could grow weed
what are you just going to plant them in
mom's garden like what's the [ __ ]
game plan what are you going to do with
those
massachusetts you grew up in like a
residential spa you're near the [ __ ]
oh
then you can float in the forest or
anything oh no no we we were like in
we were in you could plant it if you
wanted to yes
somebody's going to steal that i did it
once i did in the forest i planted one
plant
it grew a little bit and then i moved
back
i'm not kidding
um you said you're older how old your
brother uh what's the age difference
i have three older brothers that sucks
you're the youngest
out of all oh [ __ ] and that we're all
two years apart
oh that's [ __ ] oh damn your mom and
dad were gone they were making it happen
jesus every two years that means she
only had a year
in between yeah he was he was he was
relentless i
oh guess uncle my uncle got his wife
pregnant had a baby and two and a half
weeks later she was pregnant
well she was feeling the symptoms do you
know what that's disgusting yeah it was
[ __ ] disgusting
i gotta tell you i i
remember like being asked you want to be
down at the
business end for birth and i'm like no
i don't know first of all i'm not by the
way
that's not my thing like body lots of
body fluid and [ __ ] like that's not my
it's anybody's thing
no some people love it that's not my
it's 100 not my thing
a hundred percent not my thing i know
what my thing is
am i okay dude
i told you what no go ahead go ahead
body fluids no but i'll tell you what my
my thing is reminded me that i wanted to
tell you this story
so on a flight recently oh oh oh
i want to hear this [ __ ] go on on a
flight recently
i get on the plane right and we're about
10 minutes in the air
and the dude next to me goes like this
and i'm like because i'm already high
and i don't i don't want some stranger
sitting next to me on the plane like
i'm about to do something and you do you
and you're gonna shut the [ __ ] up about
it do you know what i mean
because i'm on a plane hold on was he a
white dude mexican dude black dude quite
dude
okay okay so he starts to pull open his
coat like this and i don't know what the
[ __ ]
he's about to show me he's just told me
to shut up
basically and he's opening his coat like
a truck dealer let me tell you something
right now by the way
you find out real quick real real fast
if you're a hero or not
and i am not you know what's that i was
gonna shut the f i'll scare you yeah
yeah yeah
if you listen you may let me live i
don't give a [ __ ] about the race
guess who's not taking a bullet this guy
so
but this dude in his pocket man
baby squirrel real life real
life or a baby squirrel baby tiny
squirrel that must have been kind of
cool
no man not on a plane maybe at the park
you know what i'm saying it might
there's probably a time and place for it
but not next to me on a plane
was it either the time nor the place huh
was like oh i got to know
more yeah he opens it and once you
connect eyes with baby squirrel what
happens
first of all i said how is he on planes
and he said i don't know
and i said what he goes first plane ride
and i was like what
i said what are you gonna do if he gets
crazy and he said well when he gets
crazy at the house
he had some jack daniels he goes i just
rub jack daniel that's not real
and where are you at when this happens
in the air what city were you leaving
i was leaving that uh no i was leaving
dallas
and he says i put jack daniels on my
baby squirrel's teeth you know
like in the gums just to and i'm like
like my grandmother you know
yeah like like it used to be but he
doesn't have a baby squirrel he was like
yeah it just it just
calms them down it calms a lot of people
and i was like you know but like you
know what else would come
down being outside with his family not
being in a [ __ ] place
in your pocket you yes shoved in a
pocket he's sitting next to you
yeah so did you continue this
conversation well
he at one point asked me if i wanted to
dig into his nuts and feed the squirrel
and i go
no dude i don't want to dig he sounds
[ __ ] awesome
super friendly super everything you're
telling me sounds like a new homie
everything besides the baby squirrel
part that was the
intro for me i was like yo what do you
do for a living you have a baby squirrel
i don't know
here's the deal man i'm cool if you're
going baby squirrel and that's your
thing but
baby squirrel in the on on the plane
first time
is that i was like is that your
emotional support squirrel dude like
tell me
and he was like nah i just kept it he
was like i just it's just my friend i'm
like okay
what was his name i checked out i'm so
intrigued by this person i checked out
and i'm trying to tell you why because
i in general don't like to talk on
planes not at all
no i could go the whole ride no i don't
for me i don't
no i don't need it you know what i mean
and so
the squirrel got me you know i i wasn't
excited
and then i thought i'm like well i need
to know a couple of things of course but
then
up against the window good night
everybody
jesus you you must take what how many
flights a [ __ ] month
a lot man a lot i don't even want to get
into i know you've seen some [ __ ]
i've only been on like five five flights
i hate flying
i drive what is it you don't like about
it the no control
over my life i can drive and not crash
yeah i don't know about this guy next to
me but i'll make sure to dodge him
but in the in the air the [ __ ] am i
gonna do
hey guide me through this if you can
guide me through you just fly yourself
there's no there's no i want you to
think about this though okay
and i don't want to [ __ ] you up but how
many how many
car accidents how many car accidents do
we think there are
a year hold on here's my rebuttal
to that and it's pretty good oh do you
know what i'm going to say
i know what you're going to say okay how
many plane crashes no no that's not what
i'm going to say oh
we have a different take yeah how
anybody have any idea how many car
crashes
that's 100 000 okay let's say 100 000.
okay
i don't know so out of that hundred
thousand
a hundred thousand people are at fault
right
but there are also a hundred thousand
who aren't
how do you know you're not going to be
one of the 100 000
that isn't at fault that it just happens
to
that's why i don't like planes but like
you also don't have to
it it's just one person for me i'm the
opposite for me
i feel safe in the air because it's just
one person
one person i don't have to deal with all
these [ __ ]
that's a great way to put it but when i
drive even if i'm just
high or something or smoking weed i mean
i probably shouldn't say that
when i'm just driving but i'm just
driving a
stiff cup of coffee when i'm just
driving my car i'm on full [ __ ]
militant alert everyone's out to hit me
that's how i assume everybody drives and
my whole family's truck driver so it's
like defensive driving
but your defense is your offense you
know what i'm saying yeah yeah
like predictable [ __ ] you i could see it
so
when it comes to the air in the in the
city
this way you might survive a car crash
yeah definitely not going to survive a
plane crash 100
and my luck i have really weird luck
yeah we'll land in the water
and i'll be the only one alive and then
the sharks are going to [ __ ] eat me
that's why i don't like that's why by
the way do not [ __ ] with that sounds
like you had thought that
out i do yeah that's i watched all the
final destinations
as a kid and they [ __ ] me up
what what is the what would you say is
the horror movie that [ __ ] you up the
most
chucky really i was uh deathly afraid of
chucky from
birth to about 18. my dad wait maybe you
watch it
he made me like i watched it scared me
three
yeah that would do it and then part
three i got scared i started crying
about five
and he yelled at me so you better not
not watch it and he made me watch it it
[ __ ] my whole brain up i was afraid of
chucky
i was 12 years old gangbangers are
scarier than that my town
and i was jumping from my
like my carpet of my bed over my bed so
chuck you might not
get my ankles and i'm not kidding at all
it was in my brain
that something's under my bed it's
probably chucky and that whole voice is
scary as [ __ ]
you know what man a doll did it for me
too
i think what [ __ ] well hard to say
okay hard to say i i think the movie
that affected me the
most walking out of it was
blair witch really listen man did you
see it in the theaters
yeah so i didn't know anything about it
i didn't know anything i just thought it
was a scary movie so i
i couldn't quite because i had never
seen anything shot like that before oh
i see what you're i got right i was just
like
is this real did that just happen like
it's like a snuff film
yes i totally understand like and there
weren't any actors that i recognized
do you know what i mean almost like did
they accidentally post a death
death scene in real life so much when
you were walking out of there like
because nothing had ever been shot like
that and it would and like
like i said a bunch of people you didn't
know and they were believable and they
left you at the end like yeah the
[ __ ] happened so it got me it got me
walking out of there
but like movies that freak me out
are things that could at least there's a
one percent chance it could happen
hostile that [ __ ] me up anything
that's like that might happen
hostile that'll [ __ ] me up good big time
and when i watch jeepers creepers too
it scared the [ __ ] out of me dude
i was in football we just started taking
football trips on buses they go
bro this is some real [ __ ] that justin
long is gone
they might get us i was i was [ __ ] up
when i watched it though what was that
movie
about the the family in the house and
the people show
up like in the front and they have like
masks on masks or like hoods or
it sounds like a clan no no not not that
kind of movie
they had like um oh i'm talking about
that i never watched it because i don't
[ __ ] with that i don't like movies that
make me think
i gotta check every room in my house
when i get home those are the kind of
movies that [ __ ] me up
that movie [ __ ] me up that movie was
the last movie that
my brother exactly what movie you're
talking about that's the last one my
brother visitors yes
or something like that my brother
stopped seeing scary movies with me
after that because he was like you keep
shrieking
like a [ __ ] and i was like i do huh he
goes yeah
you do i don't watch scary movies at all
oh you don't i do not watch him because
i don't like to feel [ __ ] this
like walking around in merced
by yourself that's the feeling i get
that's where i live like bro
i got to make every car is like [ __ ] i
don't know who's in this car
it sucks living like that yeah why feel
that while watching a movie no i was
watching abby gilmore again
because i'm good man i don't like to
feel
the [ __ ] panic rosie my girlfriend
loves black mirror
oh [ __ ] man that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up yeah
if you don't like to feel like that's
not it no
that's not the way to be i just watched
the office again
i'm good man um no i don't like it those
movies [ __ ] me up the realistic [ __ ]
people in your house already waiting for
you i don't i can't
kidnapping's real home invasion is real
it is so you want you give me a direct
platform to watch what could happen to
me tomorrow
i don't know like i've seen that
actually happen before
yeah she was freaking out that's [ __ ]
me up to
which one forensic file's been watching
all this [ __ ] up [ __ ] rosie loves it
i just don't like seeing people get
unjustly murdered it makes me so upset
and like i mean there's nothing wrong
with that dude that's better than you
being like you know what i love
i love seeing people being unjustly
murdered they'd be like well you gotta
no i'm talking about like when gang mega
shout out to each other i'm like yo
that's crazy
yeah some lady gets killed on their way
home like dude i can't watch this i'm
getting
i i [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah i can't watch
scary movies man
i like a scary movie um
when i'm high no that's the worst
i do i like a scary movie what am i um i
like
when you're hot yeah i'm so sorry we
just started talking
do you want some mushroom capsules do
you want one
i mean i'll have one yeah they're 0.8 i
can't really show just in case the
internet gets mad at us
you monster no water no water
every time he's even laughing he knows
you didn't get it down yet did you no
that's a big one huh
so these are mushroom capsules micro
does
look at this gary oldman man yo
if you guys haven't seen it if you're at
home look up [ __ ] gary oldman in the
professional
she eats the pills ever the first time i
met the first time i met you within 30
seconds i saw you eat
five grams of mushrooms so i thought i
can relate to him yeah
i like him over here yeah yeah oh that
by the way that first
high life we did together you had you
had to carry that for a little while
it was fine i was just looking at you
like you need help oh you need help
right now yeah
bumpers and bowling yeah you kept me in
the you kept me in the lane for a while
but it's all right that's that's fun
but but i love that you know what i love
man um
and one of the reasons i like being high
and on camera um is because
you know inevitably i'm going to say
something stupid right
right inevitably some real dome is going
to come out of my mouth
but i used to be so scared
to be embarrassed oh that
gotcha it helps me realize the next day
when i'm
fine that i'm sure we'll do that yeah
i'll write that wall for you yeah yeah
you're like oh and and what why would i
be afraid to
streak that's hilarious i mean your
brain will
open up like that on yeah yeah i love it
i
also streaking we i've done a
my fair share of i i it was a bad
example though yeah yeah
whatever reason you know everybody's got
their things you know
nudity was never my thing like being
naked that was never
i mean before my kids as soon as they
they [ __ ] that up but
well you can't walk around the house oh
yes dick out with your kids around
that's your name in your [ __ ] a piece
of your dick out kids out jesus christ
no you know what i mean like you get a
pain you gotta pant up when you have
kids you but when you have kids well
there's hume
other people are there humans yeah
especially ones yeah you gotta pant up
you know what i mean you can't be
walking around
but my dad used to go um black sock
uh blue button down shirt tighty whities
nothing else cooking pancakes oh hell no
hell yeah does he have a briefcase
that sounds like the type of person that
has a [ __ ] briefcase i don't know why
he might have had a great he might have
had a briefcase okay
he might have i mean i know there was
definitely a couple in the house i'll
tell you that that's all that matters
yeah yeah yeah
i feel like that's the era of briefcases
going to work with paperwork
you know i'll tell you something the
briefcase not as dumb
as the handkerchief like how would we
talk about this generation of people who
blew their nose and put it back
into their pocket i just i'm tripping
did we talk about this before we've
started
no i said this to myself today dude
if i blew my nose oh handkerchief people
are nasty
dude are you supposed to do with it you
have to be born in the 40s to be to have
a handkerchief i remember my grandfather
used to blow his nose in that thing and
he would
you know do one-handed he'd blow it and
then just kind of fold it up and put it
in his pocket
and then later in the day blow it put it
in the times maybe
yo but then you'd sneeze and he'd hand
you the hanky and you're like
get the plague that's how that [ __ ]
started not from rat's mom
yeah man oh so something i wanted to
bring up you just brought up your dad
i was uh listening to one of your
stand-ups pieces
you're talking about your older brother
fighting your dad and how he got his ass
whooped which was inevitable right
so and then you said you're two years
apart well he and i are six years apart
i'm two years apart from all so two my
oldest brother's two for me and then two
above him and then two above him got you
so my question was
if you're the youngest did you get your
ass whooped all the time
yeah well i mean there wasn't okay so
you're like me okay same here my sister
[ __ ] me up all the time there's no
winning a fight yeah there's no winning
it's just like oh i [ __ ] got you once
you know there was one time dude
so my brother dan let's just say he was
16.
my brother jonathan was 14 i was 12. i
had a friend of mine over
and dan and jonathan were getting into
it and we were all in kind of the living
room and
they were getting into it and danny
might have thrown him down real hard
and jonathan took off into the other
room and he comes back in with a knife
wait a second now and he picks up
danny my brother picks up my friend
there's a shield puts him in front of
him and he goes you want to stab me go
ahead [ __ ] stab me and my friend was
like no
no no no no
[Laughter]
he was like go ahead what are you gonna
do my brother was like i'm gonna fire
snap you and he's like stab me and my
friend was like dog
it was described my childhood
i was just talking about this i've
almost been stabbed multiple times it's
scary
well you're the smallest you probably
almost didn't get stuff no i never
almost yeah if you're the smallest you
probably never did but
it's real do they ever stab each other
no never got to that part no
oh [ __ ] okay did you stab your brother
oh no
my sister you almost killed me so many
times man i'm
psychotic my sister's older than me i
was really small until like
i'm still not tall right but when i was
in ninth grade
i was until then i was four eight i
wasn't even five foot i was
[ __ ] [ __ ] basically i was a tiny
little boy
and uh till what till what age until i
hit
ninth grade and i started playing well i
always played football but
you see i'll show you some pictures
after i'm danny devito
dude just a tiny little ball and smiling
had you hit puberty yet
yeah no i'm just not tall and then all
and then i got hot tall i threw a foot
in ninth grade
randomly and you were like yeah last
year i [ __ ] my sister
up yeah because i was always strong i
used to do like weightlifting
competitions and [ __ ] in high school and
i was always strong but she you know
they're older they're gonna [ __ ] you up
that's the first time
that first time you took her did she
come back
for any more smoke after that or did she
know she would never again
you don't want that smoke as soon as you
know it's over
in every way yeah it's like i'll knock
you out yeah you want to wrestle
for [ __ ] death yeah there's like
it's like [ __ ] powering up yeah yeah
hulkamania that's how i describe it's
hulk mania like
you don't [ __ ] with me dude yeah yeah
and there's and there is a
power shift and you can feel it
they don't get nicer no they don't push
it to that extent anymore in that
joke i was talking about that dads
approached
the fight with the sun differently
because
we can't lose if we lose
it's bad news you know what i mean like
if your son knows
he can beat the [ __ ] out of you
well he's just on his phone yeah okay
everybody then you know what i mean it's
a problem
that's a problem and i mean not now he
he could take me now
he just yeah he could take me now i
don't like the arrogance in that
oh he's got we sparred not too long ago
oh no
yeah he's he's let me just see if he's
faster
he's taller he's got better reach
everything is better more stamina oh and
he's also way quicker now
uh i used to be able to say
two years ago that at least i was way
stronger than him
i don't know if i could say that now how
old you jake
about to be 24. that's hard to beat
yeah here's the deal dude you know i had
a friend of mine in college
who um before he got into this
fight with this older guy he told the
dude
hey man you're going to be 40 seconds of
heavy breathing
which basically meant this dude when you
get to a certain age
yeah when you get to a certain age you
get 40 seconds of fight but there's also
a real
power called old man strength without a
doubt it is the realest thing in the
world
i almost had a deal i was going to fight
with a guarantee
vietnam vet i'd even see talked to the
man and i knew
he's been to war just by the [ __ ] the
way he approached
me i was driving my car i have an old
monte carlo so it looks like it looks
fast yeah it's a fast car
i wasn't going fast through a parking
lot he goes it's not a [ __ ] race way
as i pass him and he's six six
white dude old long like
almost like hulk hogan silky hair but
white
yeah but a full head and he was huge
like a wizard
like a wizard but only to here but he
was clean cut no beard no
nothing and i stopped my car and i go
hey man [ __ ] you and i just kept going
like
the [ __ ] yeah what's wrong with you i'm
going slow
but the car's loud or i don't know what
it is and he turned around and his wife
held his hand and he looked at me like
what what and i went into the store that
i was going in
parked my car three seconds later this
man is coming around the corner
no like this in his car looking at every
window
looking for me and that's when i
realized like i did a good thing by keep
going
because old man strength is real and he
had it well
i didn't even need to know he had it
listen you he was also a large dude
right
i don't care i don't care how big you
are but
it's the vibe that he gave hot that way
and as i've become an older man i've
figured out what old man's strength is
you know you don't have the stamina
to last the long time so you put
everything you have i think everything i
think you're right
into it and it's a combination of your
body just getting solidified
over being you know over 40 years of not
being a child anymore
your bones i think set yeah i believe it
because my grandpa is 88
and he'll definitely [ __ ] you up not you
personal i'm saying he'll
he's not a pushover he's not even big
he's smaller than i am
but he's scared i'm so glad he's not
coming after me when you were like he'll
[ __ ] you up i'm like
no no no does he hate the podcast
no my grandpa's a old uh mexican do you
remember
talking about he threw me out of 13 on
my way my grandma got thrown out at five
but like legitimately he was five so
everything in the world was like
when i was thrown out of his house at
five yeah i was in mexico
but he was in like the jungles so every
story he tells me
i listen because he doesn't talk a lot
to it to us when we're younger
and he's got some scary scary things
that he's been through and i'm
sitting here as [ __ ] his mom threw him
out because her boyfriend didn't like
him
she's like well then you're out and she
kicked his ass out he's like yeah so i
just walked to the city
and i worked for some guy i asked him if
he needed work i started making boots
[ __ ] did he ever go back and find his
mom
no but she found him later when he
started making money when he was older
it was a whole weird thing do you mind
if i ask oh oh
um did he supported her and [ __ ] when he
was older he brought her back
in no not in his house he's paid for
[ __ ] yeah but he still did that for her
and his brother that kicked him out
because he got his brother got kicked
out his older brother got kicked out
like months later
and he's like in the town like what the
[ __ ] he's like she kicked me out too and
he was seven or eight
so they went to this lady's house they
started living there
and he said that he overheard them like
it's a lot we can't really have two kids
here we're trying our best talking to
the husband that brought him in and the
lady
so his brother made him leave and he was
the little one he's like you have to get
the [ __ ] out of here
because i'm not going to like i don't
want to live outside you live outside
so you got kicked out again and it's
like a whole long
life and did he and he started his ass
right now
and my grandma's 88 oh man that's a good
dude
[ __ ] right but then again he's 88
there's a reason why he's still like
he's not in tip-top shape yeah but you
wouldn't be like
he's 60 65 because it doesn't stop
working
you know my dad is like that
my dad is 83
does he still might punch you in the
face i don't know if you punch me in the
face not you personally yeah yeah
again not you personally but somebody at
the store
being rude he i know he plays
please i know he plays 18 rounds 18
holes of golf
five days a week i know he works out
at least four days a week
at the gym james your dad's james con
jacob wolff tell what what about grandpa
is this real he's in greater shape than
all of us he can play 18 holes every day
if you want one
he's in he's is your dad big no he's
about my size
really yeah i just imagine a block of a
person right now i don't know why no
he's about my size he just
he has no off button and
isn't just like i'm like you are the
same size
that i've always known him to be that's
awesome it's crazy that's
so [ __ ] cool yeah
he is basically i mean definitely the
same size you've always known him to be
too he's the same exact size
that i've always known him to be
it's what's that
yeah he's a pretty badass dude
it's kind of cool yeah that's awesome
yeah he's a good guy
so i know we've just been talking and
ranting because
that's what we do yeah i i actually did
my homework
did my homework i want to ask you a few
things all right are you ready i did it
i
did it i'm ready to work so i'm uh i
want to know i want to know some some
things
okay i saw something about nintendo
that's like about interviewing people
yeah what year was that or how old were
you and
how the [ __ ] did that happen okay i
gotta know
i was in seattle at the time and
my agent was a woman named laura crocker
she was married to a dude named ron reed
i knew ron because ron ran the comedy
club called the comedy underground which
was to me the
still the best club i've ever played in
my entire life in seattle
in seattle and uh now it got
ruined in the uh earthquake it reopened
but
this man it was in it was a basement and
i love the low ceilings because the
energy's on top of you
do you know what i mean it lasts it has
nowhere to go but
right on top i don't think i can
experience
or relate to that like get what you're
saying oh dude it feels so alive
in that basement and and you could smoke
cigarettes
so by that late late show saturday it
was like
they were like clouds the heavy ones oh
they were like clouds right right above
it but
you just fell i just could just i felt
it on stage there
but um what were we talking about oh
[ __ ]
the comedy clothes yeah no right before
that
how did i get to the comedy club in
seattle because i asked you about
nintendo oh yeah yeah
so i can't believe i remembered that i'm
shh
i remember um so
she was like i got you an audition for
this nintendo they're looking for um
looking for somebody to do just this
industrial video
an industrial video is basically
it was on a vhs at the time and it was
being sent out
just to the people who bought the game
awesome
or or or more people from nintendo might
have gotten it but that was basically
it's cool
it was not not not that game whatever
the big
release before that game was they got
this vhs
as the it was the first time it was a
promo for this game that was coming out
but it was i don't remember what year it
was
but but it was in seattle and it was a
ton of fun right and i went in i had i
didn't know that people played video
games for a living
i was talking to these guys i'm like
what do you do and he's like hey
basically
into this room and i hit basically every
button combination
to see if there's a glitch and then i go
oh the testers then i go yeah and i go
wait this is your whole day he goes
my whole day i go how long are you going
to be on this screen he goes
two days dude how cool
how cool was that job back then oh dude
they were it was amazing and
um but then that video went so well
i got hired to do a bunch of other stuff
for them
but it was a super cool time and that
video was uh somebody sent it to me it's
on youtube yeah i said it sells
for something bill gates oh no it's uh
the actual
nintendo video oh i haven't i didn't i
didn't see that one
the actual nintendo video your promo
video for nintendo
that video was on did you have did you
have saved by the bell shapes coming out
buddy i had hair that's what i imagine
like i feel like you look like brett the
hitman heart at some point uh at that
point
you did yeah that's how i imagined you
like i had i had long hair
long curly hair down to about here hat
backwards i was wearing a vest with a
t-shirt underneath it
white big baggy acid wash sounds
amazing and doc martin's on
you were definitely in seattle oh man
you were definitely the doc martin store
oh i wanted to be dan cortese so bad i
can't even tell you do you know who that
is
he was just a guy that was on mtv he was
a
i don't know if they called him a vj and
he was just super
i mean at the time for me i'm like i
want to be that dude nice
i'm glad i didn't know no offense dad
you know i'm glad i found myself
dude doc martin store when i was a child
that's all my mom my aunt wore
and we went to the doc martin store here
in la
and i saw sarah gilbert uh from roseanne
yeah
and me i was like four and i go hey mom
that's darlene from the show we watch
that was the first time ever got an
autograph from someone
i remember i got an autograph from titus
christopher titus he's such a good guy
at albertsons and merced what the [ __ ]
that was my favorite show him and stacey
keach and [ __ ] yeah i was i remember i
was
actively watching the show and i go dad
it's christopher titus i was like 10 or
11 and he re on the back of our receipt
i still have it he wrote me an autograph
you know
i bet you he would come through here
nice i love the
robert de niro
you just pulled some [ __ ] good fella
[ __ ] here
i swear to god you looked at me and it's
all i saw
i was like what are you trying to tell
me you know what i'm saying
i didn't i didn't i swear to god
here come here tonight saturday
oh nice man no but yeah as a kid i
[ __ ] loved it
loved the show me too he's a good dude
and
a really funny guy man i really like his
stand-up
and he he writes he he
non-stop i think he's done like i i mean
not joking seven hours maybe he's really
seven hour albums
what a full the whole seven hours i bet
it feels like he's done seven at least
[ __ ] i mean i i could be i can't
i don't think i'm exaggerating but i
think seven is it
but he's constantly writing and trying
and that
and the he was first got to do with the
headset and all that stuff
and he was such a great storyteller too
i just loved it man i just loved it like
yo
everything's [ __ ] up at your house
nice i could see it on tv
yeah i mean like i saw it with my dad
one of the one times my dad was there
and [ __ ] like as a kid
and i saw it with my [ __ ] dad like i
like the show
and you're here with i just remember the
day it happened it was that i would
cross the street i lived across the
street
yeah so no i just uh the nintendo thing
man i really wanted to ask
i got to look it up it would look it up
on the uh
donkey kong country did you get to play
the game did you get a nintendo from
them
i mean yeah you should have led with
that nintendo gave me a [ __ ] nintendo
and i just did a conversation
they were super cool i mean they were so
cool man and that campus was so
crazy what do you mean well you know
just like the
oh no no no it was the microsoft campus
the nintendo was i think a couple
buildings
oh microsoft campus was like crazy damn
campus
but i can't actually i don't remember
what nintendo looked like
i remember what the front of the build i
actually think at the time was just a
building
because i remember walking in the
beginning of the video was just walking
in
it's do you get to see the hair in that
video it's i feel like i already
can see it i feel like it's brett the
hitman all the way
it is i don't know why no you're
watching it no your nails long and curls
at the end or some [ __ ]
super jewy it yeah it is exactly what it
is
yeah yeah it's
it it's not great but have you i'm sorry
cuba
no no and he's got good hair my hair
goes
like oh i've seen it yeah you turned
straight into
um back to the future yeah 100
it's not good it's great i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
because when you're 80 to 90 and you
rock it
you're gonna be the coolest [ __ ] old
man i've ever lived you know i've had
if you saw you walk by with that kind of
hair right now old ass man you wouldn't
go
i bet you he's [ __ ] awesome okay but
let me ask you something
what so i've been thinking about this
what am i gonna at 80 what are you still
allowed to wear
everything in the world we already went
through every phase of fashion now
everybody's mixing it back up
and at 80 aren't you just allowed if you
make it past 80 shouldn't you
be given some just like free passes for
some [ __ ]
yes but it depends driving no passes
whatsoever no [ __ ] off never get uber
i'll tell you something my my
grandfather
he had a theory that after he turned it
he was like
he would say i'm 80 or i'm 80 because
but he'd like to like fart in public
and and he'd be like even we're like
that's kind of funny well like a server
right here and he'd be like what can i
get you and he'd be like
i'm just looking at that battle that's
going to be my dad not change
damn it do you know what i mean damn it
that
but i think after 80 you should be
allowed to do that
yes and what i meant by driving is i'm
not giving you no breaks
you've got 40 years to learn use your
blinker that's what i mean by the
driving thing
no breaks i'm not driving i think after
80
i don't listen my grandma's 80 he still
drives
he's more competitive i think you should
have to take another test
yes yeah i just feel bad every time i
get mad at somebody driving i go by go
oh they're over yeah i'm so sorry
and i feel bad that's my past i don't
get mad as soon as i realize they're an
old old lady or old man i go
all right it's okay but here's my thing
man like so
we have like i think you should have to
test
once you every year once you get past a
certain age but like your dad sounds
like the man that
doesn't need that but then again how do
you judge that i mean
we're not we're not i'm not you know
what i mean once we get there i guess go
ahead
tesla car picks me up i don't give a
[ __ ] when my when my
grandmother when my grandmother and
grandfather were getting older
they lived in florida and there was one
time we were getting in the car with him
and my grandmother was like cause she
was a dangerous driver
she was like no you guys can't ride them
and we were like you're riding with them
she was like yeah but if we're dying
we're dying together
[ __ ] yeah
and i was like you know what that's
literally that's a pass
i get you yeah yeah then that's the pass
the pass as long as i think it's
as long as it's funny i give it a pass
not wearing pants i don't know if we
could do that one old man but
farting in public i i get that because
my dad my dad is a very funny person
dude and he
i don't think he tries to be he i don't
think he realizes that he's funny
because he's a little my dad's hilario
he says that i've had apologize for my
dad
my whole life yeah just like at the
restaurant like you said with the waiter
uh we're at uh the mexican restaurant
i can't remember it has [ __ ] beer
logos on i can't remember the name beer
though goes on
chevy's remember yes okay we're at
chevy's and merced
i'm about eight my sister's ten the
waitress
super pretty blonde girl and i can tell
that she's super pretty by the way my
dad and my uncle looked at each other
no because my dad was young when he had
me so he's like 25 and i'm like eight
probably yeah he had me like 17 18.
and my dad first thing she said do you
have anything
goes oh how about a [ __ ] that's what
he says and i know what that word means
is sex i know it's sexual i don't
fully know what it like you're in sick
back my back reverses
that's like oh i know that's something
to do with something to do with the
mouth
you know and she just obviously
hauled and he goes no no no the drink
you know with the liquor and the whipped
cream
i'm looking at my dad i look at her
he's kidding i'm eight my sister has her
head straight down
trying not to be embarrassed and then
she walks away and as she walks away
after we order
my dad just starts cracking the [ __ ] up
looks at my uncle mario and they just
start cracking up
and that that was a light that's light
yeah
dad's just like he does stuff that to me
all the [ __ ] time to him but does he
like to embarrass you
i don't even know if he's for me i think
he just wants to [ __ ] with people
you know honestly there's something look
but in a fun way yeah i'm not against
that
i'm not i've never gone you [ __ ] but
it's always
i'm so sorry dude sorry guys can i tell
you so
i like to do things to people
i like to see people's reactions i'm
excited where does this go so
i especially like to do things to people
in new york because they're
generally tense just you know they're
not used to you being overly friendly
so i like to go overboard and you know
most people are
okay but every now and then somebody
will
get really mad you know and so there was
one day
i mean this dude would get into an
elevator it was a high-rise
and i was 424 and he was floor like 48
or something you know
and we both get in and he stands to the
back left
now etiquette i'm back right
i stand middle slight left
okay so i'm not like next to him but i'm
too i'm too close for just he and i
just you in the elevator yeah just the
two of us in the elevator i did that on
purpose
and i've got my headphones in but
i'm i don't have the volume up so i mean
i'm not listening
so i can hear him but i'm doing the [ __ ]
and i hear under his
this is when i knew i was bothering him
this is all i heard him go
this [ __ ] guy and i was like
this [ __ ] guy and i was like yeah i
pushed my luck
so i go uh the [ __ ] door opens
and he goes this is your floor i go no i
think i'm gonna ride up he goes the [ __ ]
you are this is your floor and i was
like got it
was he gonna whoop your ass no he was
just like get off the [ __ ] elevator
there
see that's that's some different [ __ ]
out here you'd have to go what's the
problem
you just took it and left dude i would
knew i was bothering him
of course you know but the fact that he
said no yeah no that's a firm believer
and get the [ __ ] away from me
because even now if someone did that to
me i wouldn't like no get the
yeah i couldn't do it i think you have
to be a certain type of mean
it's for me it's super funny it's cool
it's [ __ ] hilarious of course it's
super funny because
you you're you've you've bothered
somebody
so simply but that's what i got from
being a younger brother
that those little things on how to just
twist the knife just a little bit that's
that i that's what you pick up from
being a little brother like those are
your wins your small wins are how to
just be able to go
i never that's it i never did that to my
sister
well i just got my ass oh no
i like that i mean look i it didn't
always end well
so like i remember one time i waited
at the top of the stairs to scare my
brother oh i waited
i waited and he was carrying up his
laundry basket
and i [ __ ] jumped around the corner
ha
and i scared him but he
punched me so hard in the stern
[Music]
but it was worth it of course because i
got you know what i mean okay i
understand that because i have i smashed
my sister was being mean to me and i
smashed her [ __ ] cd
case right in front of like stepped on
it and she beat the [ __ ] out of me
but i was like [ __ ] it
like yeah you don't got no cd so i do
get you i get that
just a little okay yeah why not
exactly that's exactly what i thought
and then she [ __ ] me up
but it's still i get it it was worth it
it was worth it those times i've had for
sure yeah
what else what else did you find out
online oh i'm just about to bring it up
okay
like i said i did my homework um
and it's more about i was kind of wanted
to ask i was saying i watched
a couple of at the cmt your josh wolf
show yeah all right i see your smile
when you said it all right
i want to know i know it's it's not
fully
there's it's not fully acting because
it's more of
host and yeah did you how do you like
how did you like that because i i wanted
when i saw you doing it it's more like
late night show skit i liked
the like the way you care you understand
how you can carry it
into what's coming up i
first of all i i
don't know where i just said this
but to be able to it might have been
last night
to be able to
my dream growing up was to have
a late night talk show called the josh
wolfe show
so just to be able to see it was
enough i told you it was just so much
was so much just to be like oh my
[ __ ] real
god right i know and on top of that
i he worked there so i saw him every day
we rode
drove there every day and drove home and
he had a job there everybody worked
there was
friends i put all my friends
on the couch on the panel with me it was
so much fun every day going to work
see that's why when i said it you just
lit up the second i said it
dude it was so much fun going to work
every day because you went
my dream has always been to be able to
create a fun
environment for my friends and i to be
creative
and make money damn
that's that's like and i and in for a
short while we did just that
and it was so much [ __ ] fun and
it bummed me out pretty hard for about
how long did i look like that
look like what i just
yeah bombed
no i get i know what it is it's not just
yeah you know what it was dude because
it was exactly that
that the exact thing that i had dreamed
of doing
in the exact environment
with the exact people that i wanted to
do with
every checked
yeah right and so it was you know what
it was
part of the bumming out dude was
being like so when you reach what you
think your dream is
and then it ends what do you do
that was a huge thing for me because i
was like i don't know
what to dream anymore you know what i
mean like i don't know i understand it
completely
right i get it a hundred percent
[ __ ] so it's like but i haven't been in
that position yeah
but oh
that's there's no i don't have an answer
because i have to think on that
that's a hard [ __ ] answer you can't
just come up with do this
you can't no because once you what do
you do now like already accompli
and then then i don't know you hit
another field but that's not the field
you want
no i know exactly and it just took a
second to just kind of readjust and a
second or six months whatever he said
[Laughter]
i love that you you yeah
it's totally fine man you know yeah
hey i like this little micro dose yeah
dude it's cool yep
it's not like doing anything i can't
just
no but you know i i don't know how you
use so many mushrooms to hang out
can't do that oh dude i i can't do that
i'll tell you what you know my sweet my
sweet spot is
around two to two and a half grams and i
can just sit and chill
see i've never done that i go all in
yeah
rosie all right we always eat you push
all your chips at seven to eight grams
we need an eighth
half an hour eat another eighth wait
and then we hang out i've never done
mushrooms in the daytime
oh really outside i only do them i've
done mushrooms at night with my friends
hanging out here doing this there
and i only really take them my favorite
thing i've ever done in my life the best
decision i ever
ever made yeah me and rosie ate a
quarter
and we started watching the wall which i
always know scares the [ __ ] out of me
when he gets to the hospital bed scene
and they're going through the hospital
and i always go ah turn it off i know
it's gonna i'm gonna do it and i still
do it right
the last time i usually show my house i
went to my room
turned the lights off no music
whatsoever
whoa really whoa have you ever
it's your imagination is basically
projected
and i'm just staring at what i'm
thinking because it's pitch black
there's no movement there's no sound
besides cars passing on the street
if they're if there was no sound no
music no light it's pitch black whoa
i don't think i've ever had much fun in
my whole life wow
that was the best experience i ever did
i'll tell you something
i don't
know if i trust my own brain
enough you should do you know what i
mean i know but you sh
the the reason i haven't done it again
yeah that much because i said that
i don't know if i want my brain to have
to have to hang on again
yeah tell rosie that i haven't done that
in a while like that many months
it's so [ __ ] cool man i'll try it
it is so [ __ ] cool the the the
it's like you're dreaming yeah you get
to leave and your body stays and you
just do what you want
yeah and i don't know how i can explain
that better
no that is most explained perfectly
how long do you think how long how long
did that last five hours
yeah it's crazy that you could stay in
that zone for that oh
do you know when i snapped out of it my
whole bed was
soaked and sweat yeah but that's like
that's like intense
meditation oh i was breathing in super
slow and deep just because randomly yeah
that's how i felt
the [ __ ] that happened man it was on
[ __ ] i've talked about before but
i looked down i could see myself it was
unreal i went through my roof looked
down could see myself moving
and i could feel myself moving but i
could see myself from above my house
it was amazing ten
oh ten to seven okay um let's wrap this
up a little bit oh
no head
what do you got i got can you bring can
you bring your laptop ready
i did something oh i did something i
want to know because i know you do i
like weird [ __ ] that's your thing i do
like
that's your thing yeah i know you like
weird [ __ ] i found some
weird [ __ ] i i really hope you haven't
seen it
oh i found some [ __ ] well i was thinking
in my brain
what can i type into the internet of the
earth that's gonna bring up some awesome
[ __ ] okay
so i said what are the wildest things
that people are selling on ebay
oh the [ __ ] that i found
josh you're not gonna believe the [ __ ] i
found
have you seen people sailing their teeth
oh there's there's teeth and shrunken
heads on here yeah and mummified fingers
human fingers yeah ready i'm gonna tell
you the first one okay
the first one is pickled [ __ ]
homemade says homemade and it doesn't
specify from what person or or animal
yeah that was my question the first
thing i looked at
i swear to god i searched the whole
thing and the best thing about this is
when you click on the item it just show
17 people watching
yeah there's 17 people waiting to buy
that well i will tell you
i would if i'm gonna
eat an [ __ ] i would rather have him
be pickled than probably jerky
because this can be super tough but so
i'd rather go pickled [ __ ] i think
it wasn't an option nobody brought that
that wasn't on the table no you're not
it makes sense but i would go pickle
this
it makes sense because i think pickled
probably making
it soaked in vinegar too so that's
probably fine yeah but it's not even
that it's the fact that
i've sold some already it says all their
information
how much are they going for 17 bucks
seems kind of expensive for pickled
[ __ ] right but they all look clean
i mean it's probably just rougher
[Applause]
i got i got another one that made me
very happy to find okay
are you ready for 11
you can drown that's all it says we're
selling
drown huh look and it's free shipping
for 11 bucks on ebay you can drown
and they're also selling like death
videos on there but this one i found
it's just as drowned and it has a hand
drowning
yeah man i'm not sure you should be free
[ __ ] that's cheap
11 it's [ __ ] ridiculous
that's it there's no way this is real
what the [ __ ] all right that's uh the
ebay i found all there's so much
there's so much there's this right here
i read the whole story are you ready
yeah oh yeah
so it says kansas man requested a got i
don't know what that is
game of thrones oh my god is that what
that means okay
that makes so much more sense now for
what's going to happen
so basically me let me tell you this his
pictures at the bottom oh i bet it
totally matches this whole story
this guy said uh this guy's going
through a custody battle with his wife
over the kids and he said instead of
doing
the court system why don't we have a
sword fight
right a sword fight to the death i'll
give you 12 weeks and he says i will
give you 12 weeks to get prepared make
or buy a sword
and we fight for the kids in 12 weeks
and he presented that whole argument to
the judge that's him
he's listening to limb biscuit i thought
that was fred davis
yeah but this is real this is a real
thing he said
or her attorney can take her place to
fight yeah
now listen i'm not
against it but i think it he should not
be challenging his wife to the fight he
said her or her attorney could take her
place i mean listen
and it says with samurai swords and you
have 12 weeks to prepare
this dude's been prepared exactly i see
what i'm saying
he offered that he offered that like he
had it written
swords to the death is basically yes
but i gotta tell you though dude that
that that guy when i look at him doesn't
strike me as a guy
i wouldn't look at him and be like
swordsman at all at all right
but monster energy yeah yeah dude he
a hundred percent he's sucking down
monster energies for sure
he would he i don't know he looks like
he would call me a [ __ ]
that's why i get the vibe of don't stop
at the gas station
this guy is pumping gas he's got that's
the only shirt he owns for sure
i like to see him in wife beaters anyway
i had to bring that up for you
because i thought it was [ __ ] amazing
it's a real good one
and it's an actual article yeah you have
to make sure
i you know my mind goes right to like
the balls on this guy to be like excuse
me your honor
yeah i think he's awesome yeah it's just
a i know you have your own
the fact that you thought that ideas how
this might should go but let me give let
me just throw a suggestion out at you
don't laugh me out just hear me out i
know
it's gonna start out a little weird have
you ever heard of game of thrones
i've never seen it
yeah yeah i just like the balls that he
had
just exactly the courage to ask you know
what
the worst thing that can happen is she
can't say no
exactly i'd rather not i'd rather you
pay me but the best thing
that the judge could just maybe the
judge was just
maybe it was a male judge and he was
going through a terrible divorce too
you never know he approved and he was
just kind of like i'm gonna throw a lob
it up with this guy he looks angry
enough to say yes to this
that's a that's a whole sitcom and
that's how it starts
yeah that and you just follow that man
like run running run
um also one last thing real quick before
we go
i looked it up and i made sure that it
was a thing
in new jersey it's an actual law yes
to wear a bullet proof to wear a
bulletproof vest
while committing murder it's against the
law
to have a bulletproof vest on why you
kill somebody
thank you that's the look i gave myself
huh yep yep so it's basically like hey
you shot somebody and you also ran a
stop sign
you're gonna go to jail forever oh i
just wanted to know if it was real and i
looked it up yeah
do you know what it is you know what
other law is really weird i think it's
oklahoma
oh [ __ ] you're not allowed to wash your
donkey
in the bathtub how many people got hurt
doing that today
that's the first thing i think because
now that i think about it i could see
someone trying to do that
100 yeah i don't know where else you'd
wash your donkeys where
exactly you live in an apartment
building oh you guess you put them in
the tub right don't you put them in the
tub [ __ ] yeah let's put them in the tub
and they probably broke so many tubs
that people were like all right
we're making a lawn
by the way if you live in oklahoma i
don't know if that's it i'm just
sorry i'm just kind of new jersey i'm
sorry if you're out there killing people
guessing i'm just
no best i'm just guessing um um
but yeah man i appreciate you having me
out brother
sorry that joint is murdering me yeah
all right before we get out of here
thank you so much thank you man thank
you i like this micro dose like once
again i
i like it like we're going straight into
high life we're going to go straight
into that
the highlight and ah before we get out
of here please you have
a live special oh yeah yeah um
oh yeah yeah february 6th
february 6th you're doing a live special
[ __ ] up
you've got one take i'm doing a live
comedy stream
uh eight o'clock central um if you go to
comedianjoshwolf.com you can get some
tickets
it's just 9.99 and uh listen man you
know
also doing this ourselves right
that way we don't have to give our money
to anybody else
and they don't get to tell us what to
say what to say
or how it should look or anything
you get which is what it should be it
should be in the hands of the artist so
i'm so happy to be doing this
i think it's cool man i appreciate it i
think it's cool because if i i don't
know
i know i do all those videos i could not
do it you are seasoned
i might be able to do that [ __ ] i'm
gonna tell you what i'm gonna tell you
the real truth about this right because
of kobe
i will have only run this set
five times before i do the special you
can't be on mushrooms doing this [ __ ]
hell no i can't remember nothing no i'm
just re i i'm
i'm if this is the first time in a long
time
where i've been in the books nice you
know what i mean
because i can't really get up and do it
as much as i want
but um it's it's made the writing a
little different
it's kind of fun man i'm excited i'm
going to be february 6
at 8 o'clock central but go to comedian
joshua.com for tickets
nice [ __ ] uncut
and if you like the special that's on
youtube um father of the year you're
really gonna like this one
nice i appreciate that i'm [ __ ]
excited to watch that i appreciate it
dude thank you for having me
thank you for thank you for coming we'd
even talk about tennessee but
we'll talk about that in a minute but
yeah thank you so much for coming thank
you for coming out
thank you guys so much for watching this
is josh wolfe check them out at we'll
leave all the links
below thank you guys so much for
watching this is the first guest thank
you so much josh thank you
first guest to be here thank you so much
dude thank you
this has been the dope as usual podcast
i am dopa ziola thank you guys so much
for watching
have a dope stay
all right that was awesome dude
i can't i could i got to build up the
mushroom tolerance to talk
i don't know how you keep [ __ ] going
yeah
and this is a this is nothing this is a
touch in your brain
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect